[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now it is time
for this week's pet project amy lee
joins us from the nspca
and she brought along someone who needs
a sweet and caring and safe home
but this one's a little baby it's a
little guinea pig isn't she
so cute her name is
they're so unique they are so
communicative and they make great
starter pets for
a lot of people don't take up a lot of
room and they love to make that you know
they make a lot of noises they talk to
each other they pop poor when they
get excited which is really cute if
you've got veggies they come in and they
don't start hopping up and down
oh my goodness i can't stop smiling
she's really cute make her it was just
so unique about them and
yeah they're so fun um and they don't
take up a lot of room in your home and
we have so many people
looking for great homes and great
families and hopefully somebody will
adoption tyrell she's only 10 months old
oh my gosh it's like a cartoon character
in real life it's so cute she's so cute
um and amy you told me that you guys
have an abundance of small pets usually
we have
cats and dogs on but tell us more about
your your small pets and what you guys
offer
yeah absolutely so aside from just
guinea pigs which make great pets we do
have a lot of baby rats you know there's
i know you know a lot of people
we have a lot of bunnies that are
looking for homes as well so if you just
visit our website we've got
you know you'll check them out and just
schedule appointment and come on in i
love that okay so tell us about the
actual adoption process how can people
how can people do it walk us through
yep absolutely you're going to visit our
website at nevadaspca.org and you're
just going to go to the small pets page
or the dog page or the cat page whatever
you're looking for
you're going to click the green make an
appointment button schedule your date
and time and there you go
you'll get a confirmation email and just
come on in boom boom thank you so much
amy for everything you guys do and
lastly here
i think you answered it earlier but how
can you take care of a guinea pig what's
the
what's the process there well you know
they're they're actually not that
difficult to take care of they just need
a good enclosure for them they like to
play with toys they need something to
hide in
and then we'll our adoption counselors
will guide you through the best
practices for them
perfect like you said a great starter
pet so we're excited to see who gets
adopted thank you amy
bye goodbye guinea pig so cute all right
if you're interested in adopting a pet
or a guinea pig
go to nevadaspca.org or call them at
we
702-873-7722